one of the best in the biz and I'm not
just saying that because she does it for
the NFL Network but a DD King Kabbalah
knows so much about the Steelers and as
much as anybody else and she joins us
here on the program hi doing a DD that's
a heck of an introduction reg it's true
I'm glad you're not holding it against
me that I called you Monday morning
saying what is wrong with people
no but you you know you know you know
what's going on so what did what's the
headline out of the Tomlin press
conference today the DD this is pure
speculation but I think this marriage is
over I think that's the headline
I think there are multiple headlines one
I think that this was perhaps the best
thing to happen in the Steelers I've
already had multiple members of the
organization at plausible levels
say that this is good because now it
means there'll be action and consequence
and had they gone to the playoffs
perhaps everything would have just been
pushed under the rug like it was last
year when Mike Mitchell was screaming
into the Jaguars locker room and lay me
on bail was late to a walkthrough so
perhaps it's good because now there will
really actually be changed also I think
a headline is that Mike Tomlin didn't
mince words on Antonio Brown when he was
asked is there a point when it's not
worth it anymore with a challenge it's
not worth it and his response was
certainly that's pretty telling
and we've had I've had multiple players
which tell me that they are done they
are done with the antics they're done
with the drama and that they found
Antonio Brown tapped out another
headline I think my comments still in
trouble over this whole injury thing I
don't know rich were you buying it were
you buying that yes Antonio Brown really
had
discomfort in his knee if he never
showed up to his MRI no I don't buy much
of this though Aditi it's everybody's
covering for everybody else because
nobody looks good in this situation I
had Ryan Clark on in our number one from
ESPN and you know what comments he said
on on SVP a couple nights ago about
Antonio Brown when he first got the
money in Pittsburgh when they were
teammates back in that day when they
chose Antonio Brown over Mike Wallace
which was obviously a very smart
football decision but I asked Ryan
who's lost the locker room the most the
quarterback the wide receiver the coach
and he gave the the the caveat of I love
him but he chose Mike Tomlin a DD as he
has he lost the locker room do you think
you know it's funny because I had two
players text me today rich and say
exactly the same thing I thought that
this was a different Mike Tomlin that we
thought today I felt that he was
chastened I felt that he was
acknowledging that he wasted a prime
opportunity this year I felt that he
owned the issues that sunk the Steelers
this year which is basically rich the BS
and the distraction but two players
texted me and said he didn't go far
enough and he still needs to make a
major statement if he wants the locker
room back very young player juju Smith
Schuster said to me on Monday no one
player can be bigger than the team when
you're second-year receiver is saying
that and your head coach isn't proving
that to the players just yet then Ryan
Clark is right that is an issue and I
think might and that's why I'm saying
that's why I think the headline is that
Antonio Brown is on his way out is sort
of the headline because if Mike Tomlin
is going to win this locker room back if
Mike Tomlin is going to show there is
indeed going to be real change then
what's the biggest statement that you
can make other than perhaps sending away
two of the ten best players in the
league Le'Veon Bell and Antonio Brown
letting two of the ten best players in
the league leave and saying we think our
team will be better without you both
it's just so last one for you here
Aditya did he can't Apollo my colleague
from the NFL Network joining me here on
the show where does Big Ben stand in all
this I mean where work how did how does
the team move forward with him when
everybody saw I guess in the walk
through what he then denied on his radio
show either out of wanting to keep his
fingerprints off of it or make an
awkward attempt at deflecting blame off
of his wide receiver I mean what was he
you know you and I have talked about
this privately and now we did talk about
it publicly
many a time this team knows what it
hasn't been Roethlisberger it knows the
ways in which his personality is very
material if that's a diplomatic way to
say it what really struck me yesterday
is the way that he talked about Browns
aways and oh he's one of my closest
friends oh I want it back Oh whatever it
was so reminiscent of the way he talks
about Todd Haley last year the Tuesday
after the season ended he could not have
been more positive could not have been
more glowing and he knew at that point
already that Todd Haley was gone
so we talked percentages in this
business the percentage of Antonio Brown
and Ben and Tomlin are all starting week
one for the Steelers is what do you
think ten maybe okay five I think it's
very very low I mean it's always
possible the Tomlin wouldn't even answer
what does Brown need to do to get back
in your good graces what does Brown need
to do to win his teammates back I mean
this is the issue rich if your teammates
believe that you tapped out if your
teammates say you were a distraction to
the point of we could not concentrate on
our game if your teammates say that they
have lost trust in you then doesn't
really matter how dynamic of a talent
you are this Terrell Owens know the
answer to that thanks for the call of DD
great stuff is always really appreciated
thank you you bet that's a DD King
Kabbalah check her out on NFL total axes
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience